das reicht doch erst mal von einer von
der länge oder reicht so wie dein glied
vor der länger reicht ist aber wann man
denkt einfach ist es vielleicht auf
dauer hingesehen zu wähnen also man weiß
halt nicht genau sie ihre tiere
kastrieren einfach eine tür einbauen
warum weil es dort so gut aussieht guckt
man das aber nicht mal symmetrisch man
da musst du hier noch ein weiter gehen
um sie bietet wird 123 41 23 museen
weiter gehen hier noch mehr musste ein
weitergehen zwei muster gehen müssen
vier ich mach das schon verstehen willst
geh ich auch nicht ich weiß auch noch
nicht aber es hat einfach so wir machen
einfach die tür zu nix sie wird einfach
ein ausgang und wohin führen aber vom
keller auch mal wieder rauskommen und
habe ihr gelbes zeigt hier ist colo colo
colo brauchen wir ganz viel für diesen
extractor apropos die meint nicht nur
die kohle raus nehmen wir das riverboat
weg ist weil sonst der generator stoppt
halt nicht so wie offen so mehr brauchst
du mir nicht helfen danke bitte der
müssen nach einer wand einreißen
was muss nein nein nein wir müssen keine
mehr guck doch simon 34 müssen wir nicht
ich weiß ich habe recht ich habe immer
recht
das ist so einfach gefallen berka club
wo alles schön hätte viel aber die war
die lavaasche eine sehr gute idee von
mir passiert immer mal ein wenig dass
ihr der angedeutet haben und am boden
aber und die decke weiß ich dass wir
nicht so gut gefällt ist das wasser also
ich würde jetzt übertrieben wenn über
dem wasser und der lage das wasser
direkt machen nur die lover lassen den
marmor daraus der bei der lava da ist er
wieder der bei dem wasser da ist dann
haben wir auch schon die decke
und nein aber das muss jetzt ein
zwischending man versteht was man egal
du musst auf jeden fall mal finden mama
waren unsere alten höhle dahinten dabei
richtig viel aber auch in anderen willen
hier ist richtig viel marmor sind die
wir aufnehmen
80 minuten ok dann würde ich einfach mal
sagen leute die werde schonmal dran
unsere stimme jetzt zu hören
noch hinkt er dann machen wir
schnellstens abschluss was ja schon aus
wie du nicht mehr stemmen die sehen uns
morgen wieder vorbei ist so glänzend das
fahrzeug
ich sag mal fcb lp gucken wir mal von
crafter vor einer stunde von crafter
vize biest viel zu visp macht euch ein
mining laser das eine echt geile sache
was ist was hier in mailand mason ich
gucke mal in diesem rezept das ist mein
laser oder the thing mining laser dafür
brauchen wir einen redstone eine energy
christel noch ein lg crystalline
advanced secude 14 advanced allgäu und
dann kriegen wir einen mining laser da
kann man so mit laser alles verstrahlen
was bringt das was bringt uns das sind
mal das gut im griff das gerät mal über
handy spiele suchtgefahr was ihr zockt
und vielleicht auch minecraft pnp
wenn sie noch nicht ach so dass die
mobile version echt nicht ich schon aber
alle meine freude am what's up und ich
nicht whatsapp ist cool
herbst ich hab's an die bundes
zur nächsten folge wenn wir die drohnen
befinden sondern würde ich sagen ja die
musik doch erst mal runter bringen naja
es gibt ja nichts neues auch spannenden
abschluss machen kommt das ist ein
turnier machen das große thema
ich würde jetzt sagen nein wir noch fünf
minuten in 5 minuten
jetzt müssen auch wohin das ein
abenteuer erleben alles was wir alles
was wertvoll ist das zitrone tun und
dann das ist einfach ein abenteuer leben
das zu erreichen setzt gleichen sucht
ich habe 30 leveln ein die man die mit
ganz lang machen
ich möchte abenteuer erleben allein am
tag als ich brauche sind dafür nur eine
spitzhacke und schaufel essen und
vielleicht diese fakten her auf den
kampf in fünf minuten ich werde mir doch
sollte hier eine neue beute 1,4 haben
wir brauchen was ihr was ihr da warst du
wirst wie saphir
ich habe die baustelle wo die dinge sich
die was die vorträge an
ach so ja warte ich hab den portal hier
machen und dann mit ihrem spruch ich hab
dich hingeworfen ok danke schön herr
dachte okay leute jetzt geht's jetzt
geht's los jetzt geht's los
was machst du denn zwerg der hoch
du hast jetzt mit der portolan einmal
die kleinen sachen denke schon
ich nehme jetzt mal das ganze war erst
mal weg und geht sowie den eindruck man
wolle die stadt bis der stadt ins haus
zu treffen
nein so weit gewesen so hier ist was
frisch hier ist was frisch etwas frische
etwas frisch das fleisch von welcher
stadt lässt ihn jetzt in unserer anfangs
statt was soll da rocha la musica noch
nicht was es bringt zu schützen
hier kommt jetzt ganz viele samen und
sei daraus soll ich hätte was seide
bringt vielleicht für wolle oder so
damit wir bald gar keine schafe weil wir
dieses andere komische dinge achtet
einfach pumpkins
ich habe neues feld gefunden was wir
vorher nie gefunden haben die ja da ganz
oben links
doch das habe ich schon mal gesehen dann
ziehen wir an
ganz wie weizen das wäre alles kaputt
kartoffeln
und noch mehr weißen ich hab noch
nirgendwo erlebt hier das abenteuer des
verlorenen feldes da ist es mehr das
große meer
ich hoffe ich hoffe wir finden uns bald
wieder zu einer anderen zeit von einem
san do alter ich bin zu weit entfernt um
jemals zurückzukehren
süß paar grad die kür
sie ist ich finde daraus geworden was
denn beim korn von einfach so essen kann
ich auch nicht dass auch bei dem ein
junger beamter
dann könnt ihr nicht so aber nicht
zusammen starten
ich komme ich zu dir muss wieder zurück
kommen wir nur zwei minuten bisschen
tiefer so ich komme zurück in ein
bisschen tiefer ich bin selbst in der
höhle und versuch reisen reisen habe ich
aber ich versuche marmor zu finden
versucht auch mal was mitzunehmen
habt ihr keinen wollte etwas finden
abseits stehenden kommando stehen
kommando
sie kassieren harten landung gestern als
hartz4 und werden nach 24 flaschen zu
rambo auch sache ich sterbe jetzt
einfach fast als auffällig ganz schön
level wie portugal
lass ich sterbe dass die partner dabei
mit wasser gebohrt ich komme ich zu dir
dann werden wir die folge lecker post
ich habe noch gut futter geholt und hab
ein bisschen die puste aus wird brauchen
wir eine zweite lange zusammen sind vor
thailand zu erleben
der dumont selbst finden dass er meine
eigentlich ja es gibt noch die potato
portal gun die alterskollegen die bacon
vorteil ganz ehrlich es gibt auf die
potenz die haben andere als leicht aber
die die vorteil ist dass die voll ist
dass die die wasserrinne ihr braucht man
keine eingangstür
wir brauchen einfach nur total ich weiß
ja um ein cockpit verfolgten weg
abgekürzt ja ganz einfach durch die tür
gehen kommt jedes quartal mit ich werde
ich schreib doch dann eh wieder aber
doch ja so gut gemacht
das tier bei simon richtig viel essen
und nahrung für unser feld so die folge
ist aber vorbei und sagte ich sagen
wünsche euch dass die leute das noch
ganz gut sehen ich nehme jetzt du bist
erst mal eine portman zurück und ich
nehme jetzt raus und hier die kohle hat
dies schon links raus
einfach damit das ganze nicht 1000 jahre
weiterläuft danke jungs
wenn ich gestorben mehr alter nein und
ich bin auch so eine treppe gefallen
jetzt was es sein sie wollen wir im
haushalt hab jetzt was es sein wird
wirklich bitte ok ich töte dich jetzt
hab ich grad zurück
sie war auch widerstehen
ich bin fast tot ok ich hab' ich sagen
was ist von uns für die folge war dass
die posierte da und hab' ich sage und
schreibe wieder vielleicht kommentare
schreibt ihr fleißig vorschläge für
themen und so weiter bis zum abschluss
nochmals portal rein oder dass ein
portal ist da oben passiert nichts da
würde ich sagen ja